foreign
[Music]
is extremely reliable that said though
those extreme events and the more
frequent occurrence of those events and
the intensity of those certainly is
exposing the grid more recently to to
things that maybe the grid wasn't
designed to handle we've seen an
increasing number of what folks would
call you know a one in one hundred year
type of event or 150 year event six of
the seven largest wildfires in
California history have happened since
2020 just in the last couple of years
right the extreme temperature events
that we've seen with the winter storm
Yuri in 2021 and what we saw just here
in the last couple of weeks with winter
storm Elliott or maybe it's hurricanes
and you know the hurricane intensity and
frequency like we saw with Ida down in
New Orleans it's not just weather cyber
security so there are bad guys out there
that would like to be able to leverage
you know vulnerabilities that they could
find with cyber or May maybe physical
security people actually taking and
shooting ballistics into uh into
substations two power substations were
targeted in a gunfire attack this
weekend it led to several equipment
failures 45
000 people at the height at customers
that is at the height of the power
outage not being able to have any power
increasing protection at utility
substations May soon be a new practice
for power companies across Washington
and the U.S detectives are looking for
the person or persons who knocked out
four utility substations in Pierce
County even setting one on fire the the
electric grid is really a system of of
components it's a system of generators
which are devices that actually create
electricity from from various primary
sources of energy that energy is then
delivered through a delivery system that
transmits and delivers that electricity
to the places where we consume it to our
houses businesses or whatever there's
over 400 000 miles of transmission lines
there's over 5 million miles of
distribution lines in the U.S and all of
that has worked together to make sure
that when you flip that switch on in
your house the light comes on just then
and grid operators actually have to
manage it so that just in time that
energy is there when it's needed because
they have to maintain a balance at all
times between supply and demand so it's
pretty complicated there's the Eastern
grid there's the Western grid and then
there's a grid that's a big portion of
text is not quite all of it those grids
are very very Loosely interconnected so
the connections between those three
grids are what we call asynchronous
meaning that an issue that starts to
happen and
hopefully would never actually Cascade
into a complete blackout that wouldn't
go beyond those individual grids we
really want to avoid any type of event
that could result in a long duration
outage but when they do happen we want
to be able to recover very quickly and
so heart of resiliency is making sure
that we don't get to those long duration
outages by putting in systems that allow
us to be able to recover quickly when
you drive down the road and you see
those large power transmission towers
that are there or even the maybe the
overhead poles on the street that are
bringing the lines to your house we can
design those in a way such that if an
event happens where the winds are much
more than we would have ever expected
for our planning basis you basically can
actually recover much more quickly
whether it be the structure of being
hardened against that like we try to do
with with new structures for
transmission down in Louisiana or
whether that be the the pole beside your
house if a tree limb Falls across the
line rather than the entire pole being
dragged down which takes longer to
replace you might want it to actually
pull away from the pole and there's
designs that we work on and develop
different resources have different
contributions to reliability and to
resiliency right and all of them have
contributions we see some high impact
events where you have really good
production from wind and solar but
during the night if it's really really
cold like we saw during winter storm
Elliott solar performed really really
well during the day I mean it was really
rock solid in there and didn't have some
of the problems that maybe we saw with
some other resources but at night you
get none of that and the load stayed
steady at night and so you you don't
have the ability to provide that so how
do all those resources come together you
know and it is a mix of resources
whether that be nuclear and our existing
resources gas is obviously very
important we still have coal out there
that contributes you know now that will
be phasing out as we go forward in the
decarbonization out to Net Zero the the
grid is going to only be increasingly
important as we go forward our modeling
basically shows that in order to achieve
the decarbonization targets that we have
here in the U.S which the Bible
Administration has set for us that we
want to be Net Zero by 2050 across the
full U.S economy our models basically
show that in order to make that happen
the most economic Pathways for that are
for the electric grid to be used to help
decarbonize the other uh other energy
sectors Transportation obviously
becoming electrified buildings with heat
pump space heating water heating those
types of things becoming electrified
even portions of Industry are also
becoming electrified our models say that
the most economic Pathways will have the
electric sector serving
40 to 60 percent of our total energy
needs as we go forward reliability and
resiliency are the foundation of the
grid being able to do that in order to
achieve that we'll have to all continue
to work together to innovate to invest
to make sure that we have those
resources that are available for the
grid to provide for us as we meet